In this Cloud Minute, I want to show you
how to manage Google Cloud resources using PowerShell
Cloud SDK for Windows comes with a set of PowerShell
cmdlets for accessing and manipulating Google Cloud resources
such Cloud Storage or Compute Engine
Let's install Google Cloud SDK for Windows
During installation, make sure PowerShell is checked
Once installation is complete, we need to authenticate using
gcloud auth login
Now, we're ready to use cmdlets
Open PowerShell and as an example, let's create a Cloud Storage
bucket using New-GcsBucket cmdlet
Or we can get information about our Compute Engine
instance using Get-GceInstancde cmdlet
For the full list of PowerShell cmdlets
see the link in the description